together
we are capable
of great things?
A better way to build a faster way to grow
a smarter way to do business.
But the world is still a big
place from high rise conference rooms to factory floors across
thousands of miles and multiple times owns an yet we
should be able to work together to be together.
To collaborate from anywhere anytime as if in the same
room we should be able to do all of this
to move between contacts between devices
and across geographies.
Hold on
one second.
We got it yes communication
is at the core of what it means to be
human it defines us and shapes our ideas are reality.
Now no matter where we are we can communicate across
our organizations with our customers and partners and with the
most important people in our lives all from a single
secure place this is life like video.
Voice instant messaging and meetings available from any of your
devices for communicating with virtually anyone
who and bringing human connection
to every
conversation.
I hang out. well it went very well I'll be
home soon.
technology and powering the most fundamental element of communication.
Us.
This is
Lake.